my father was a disciplinarian he was  also in the Air Force up he hit me he  never beat me he never abused me but  there was certainly a realm in which I  if I [ __ ] up I get slapped only  happened two twice maybe ever but I knew  it was an option  twice in my life yeah because and I say  this I said this on I said this on  Twitter  when I had a Twitter account so I'm  saying the hitting kids is bad and I  said yeah I understand you can't abuse  kids it's a fine line I know it's a very  nuanced detailed argument but in the  real world there are lines that if you  cross violence appears like it in your  face as a man and start running my mouth  sooner or later it becomes physical  that's the real world so as an  upbringing of a child I think there  should be lines if they're crossed  violence appears I don't see anything  wrong with that I was never abused in  any way but if I really [ __ ] up and  both times now and Ryan's like massive  and I learned and I was taught that's a  line